When you write code as part of a team, picking good class and method names
makes it possible to work together. When I pick good names for my classes, it
makes it easier for other engineers I'm working with, to read my code, and know
what it does. It also makes it easier for me to remember what I did. So, this
process is important, but how do you get good at it? The answer is practice.
Lots of practice. Keep writing code, and when you read code, ask yourself, what
patterns does this code follow to make it easier to read. Or, what patterns
could this code have followed to make it easier to read. These questions will
be very hard to answer, at first. But as you critique more examples, it'll
become more natural. We'll talk about a few more patterns in this lesson. But
for now, let's do another example of designing class and method names.